CHRIS CARTLAND: Welcome to the
Google+ Partner Showcase.
My name is Chris Cartland, and
I'm a developer programs
engineer working on the
Google+ Platform.
Today, we're very lucky to have
with us a special guest.
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Hi.
I'm Lefteris Haritou.
I'm working at Snapette
Incorporated.
And I'm the lead Android
and iOS engineer there.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, this
is really exciting.
So since we launched Google+
Sign-In, we've had a lot of
different companies
and developers
integrate with Google+.
But one thing we keep getting
asked is how's it working.
And whose implementing this?
And tell me more about
what this is
like in the real world.
So today, we have Lefteris here
with us from Snapette to
help talk about what it's
like in the real world.
What it's been like integrating
with the product.
How that has helped
the application.
And so we're really excited to
get that real feedback from
someone like Lefteris.
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Yeah, we had
great success with the Google+
addition to our application.
We've seen great numbers.
We've seen an increase on total
users that are signing
up to our app.
It was a very easy
integration.
The documentation
is very clear.
And it has been a success
story, basically.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
awesome.
So can you explain a little bit
about your app, so we can
see why a user would
want to sign-in.
Or why do you want the user
to sign-in to your app?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Yeah, our
app is a mobile fashion
application.
So it socially scores
to our application.
So we want our users
to engage.
So one way is through
user sign-up.
And Google+ has significantly
helped here because it's a
driver for new sign-ups.
The more users that's signing
up with Google+ and sharing
with interactive posts, the more
users we are getting on
our platform.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
awesome.
So before you had Google+
Sign-In, have you noticed the
change between that time
and now after you
have integrated it?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Yeah.
Actually, since we integrated
Google+, we've seen a bump of
about 7 or 8% on
total sign-ups.
So with Google+ more users have
been willing to sign up
to our application
and increase our
registered users database.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's great.
So in order to get that much
benefit, how much effort did
it take, like, in your
integration?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Yeah, the
integration was very easy.
We went through the
documentation,
which is very clear.
We benefited from the
sample code that is
available on the website.
So it was very easy
implementation, quick
implementation, and
effortless.
Everything went smoothly.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's great.
Did you learn anything, while
integrating, that surprised
you either from the developer's
perspective or
[INAUDIBLE]?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: From the
developer's perspective,
nothing surprised us.
I mean, the documentation was
there to provide to every
question and every answer
to our questions.
And like I said, the sample
code was a great start-up
because you can actually
download the sample code.
And, pretty much,
use a lot of the
sample code that's available.
And just copy-paste it
inside your app, and
get you quickly started.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's great.
Yeah, so you've added Google+
sign-in but you had other ways
for a user to sign-in before.
And I was wondering if you
have noticed how that has
compared to the previous ways
that a user could sign-in.
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Yeah.
Our app is social.
So we get to [INAUDIBLE]
of signing up to our app.
So in the Android Platform,
we've seen, naturally, that
since Google+ is available,
about 40 or 45% of our users
are using Google+ to sign-up
to the platform.
On iOS the numbers
are a bit lower.
But still they are about
the same with our
rather social providers.
So it's actually doing very well
on that part, as well.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
very good.
And between all of these
providers and the ones you've
added, do you have any numbers
about what the increase has
been from before and after?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Yeah.
In total sign-ups, we went
from 43% of total user's
signing up on the app to 50%.
And these numbers are, like I
said, 45% on Android, 40 or
45% are using Google+.
And on the iOS platform,
29% are using Google+.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's great.
So you, actually, went from
less than half of your
visitors in your app had signed
in to now you have more
than half that have signed in.
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Exactly.
CHRIS CARTLAND: This is a
great way of converting
visitors within your app
to actual users.
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Exactly,
and that's what we
are trying to do.
So we are trying to engage the
users to sign-up and get them
back to the app.
This is one way.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
very good.
Cool.
So we've talked a lot
about sign-in.
And that's getting a user
to become a full
user in your app.
And then, once they're there,
you mentioned a little bit
about interactive posts
and sharing.
So I was wondering if you could
talk a little more about
that integration.
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Yeah, we use
both interactive post and
normal sharing in our app.
So every social activity that
will take place in our app is
going to be shared
on your moments.
And there is also
the interactive
posts, which is great.
We are benefiting from the
interactive post capability,
so we are actually using the
deep linking capabilities.
So this is also a driver of
users to our app because
interactive post and [INAUDIBLE]
help getting users
to your app.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Can you tell me
a little bit about what's
special about interactive
posts?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: The
interactive post was very
easy, first of all,
implementing it.
It's a quick implementation,
very easy to implement, and
the users have total
control over it.
So it has been great for us.
And it's also helping our
application getting more users
by the depleting capabilities
in our app.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And there's a
call to action button in a
interactive post, which is how
interactive posts are special
from regular posts.
LEFTERIS HARITOU:
Exactly, yeah.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Could you tell
us what action you chose to
put on that?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Yeah, the
action depends on what you are
going to see.
So if an item is available for
e-commerce purchase through
our external links it will
show the buy label.
But if it's something that's
not available for buying
immediately, it will say want.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Want, OK. so I
want this item, and you can
click that button
if you want it.
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Exactly.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And that takes
you, of course, deep into the
app, helps you download it, if
you don't have it already, and
then you have it.
Very good.
How did you go about
the decision of
choosing that label?
I know I've talked with a lot
of developers who want to
implement interactive posts, and
it takes them some time to
figure out which label
to pick because
there's a bunch of them.
LEFTERIS HARITOU: For us, it
was very straightforward
because we always hit the like
button, which indicates that
like is something that
you would want.
So there was also no discussion
of whether we'd
call it like or want.
So it was a very easy decision
for us making
the label as a want.
And for buy, of course, it's
very straightforward.
I mean, this item is available
for purchase, so you might
want to buy it.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
And for the web component you
talked about the mobile apps.
How important is mobile
to your application?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: We are a
mobile application, basically.
So this is our main part.
We can go to the website, but
the main focus, right now, is
on the mobile applications.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And have you
been able to take advantage of
or use over the air installs in
order to help [INAUDIBLE]?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: This is
something that also helped us.
We have also added the ability
for a user to sign-up on a
website with Google+.
So we are also benefiting from
over the installation and
[INAUDIBLE] login.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And
I know that you
mostly worked on mobile.
How hard was it for the web
team to [INAUDIBLE]?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: The web team
didn't hit any problems.
There was also sample code
which they used samples
available documentation.
So it was very easy to
implement, as well.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's great.
Is there anything that you've
learned through integrating
either for Android developers or
for companies that want to
use Google+ in their
application?
Do you have any advice for
those kind of people?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: My advice is,
first of all, go to the
documentation website.
With the documentation
it's very clear.
It's very easy to read.
Download the sample code.
Use that sample code in
your application.
Take advantage of all
the features that
are available there.
So use interactive posts.
Use [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] is very powerful.
It will drive people to
download your app.
So this is certainly something
you wouldn't want to miss.
And benefit from whatever you
can from the technology.
[? Seize it, ?]
implement, and it pays back.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's great.
And for all the links, we'll
post all the links with this
video so that you can go find
the documentation for yourself
at developers.google.com/+.
Is there anything else you'd
like to share about your
experience with Google?
So not just with the integration
but with using the
different features.
How has this made your
product better?
LEFTERIS HARITOU: The product
is, first of all, made better
because it's easier for
a user to sign-up.
We provide another option.
Google+ is very popular.
Everyone has a Google account,
so it helps users signing up.
So this is definitely
something you
don't want to miss.
And the implementation
is very easy.
So it shouldn't take more
action for a experienced
developer more than half a day
of implementing the Google+
implementation sign-up
on his application.
Something no one wants
to miss, I believe.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's great.
Great.
Well, thank you, so much,
for joining us.
It was great to talk to you
about your integration.
And we hope that the success
that you seen, so far,
continues to make your app
grow and turn more of the
people who see your app
into dedicated users.
LEFTERIS HARITOU: Thank
you for having me.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah,
thank you.
So we'll be back again, every
week, with Google+.
Check out the documentation at
developers.google.com/+.
If you have any questions about
how to integrate, you
can join us in our developer
community on Google+.
Or you can ask questions
on "Stack Overflow"
with the tag Google+.
So please check out our samples,
and thank you so much
for watching.